bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovissimo video di anime tormentate
video mr più o meno di o meno questa
premessa al volume proprio al volo un
pochettino di febbre perché ho fatto il
vaccino da pochissimo è venuta qualcuno
venisse sono un po smorto e solo per
questo motivo amato bene cioè mister
emiliano che comunque qualcuno viene da
sé fa se non esce niente quindi non
siamo su alimentati italiano che questo
gioco che ha attirato tantissimo la mia
attenzione perché è molto molto simile
ai vecchi residenti voli in sono pure a
silent hill senso a quel mood elia che
di telecamere li si ho avuto molto bello
di star game
siamo in un hub e belle john carico nel
cuore del quadro c'è un cane già il
gioco dell'anno sto vedendo scusa make
up singole cos'è gli ha dato vi dico
makeup queste attenzioni credibile
faccia sorpresa è bellissimo perché
giallonero è veramente una lettera per
me non ho mai ricevuto lettere però non
è vero di farle ricevo quindi io c'è più
gente che mi vuole bene a questo si può
aprire stati eccola qua eccola qua la
mia testa cosa è stato pensi che poi
abbandonarci qua così una fotografia di
due ragazzi che sembrano gemelle ma che
cazzo ne frega a me ne sono passate due
settimane da quando ricevuto con la
lettera non son riuscito a stare
tranquilla non riesco a togliermi
immagini quelle due ragazze la mia
tenente dal contesto sportivo a
svegliare la notte quando finalmente nel
documento o un sacco di ho bisogno di
sapere cosa succedendo qual è il
significato di tutto questo non lo so ma
l'italia vittorio europei ho bisogno di
sapere abbiamo raggiunto l'ospedale che
comunque un ospedale un attimino che
urla non ci andrei di notte primo due
come cacchio ci sia arrivata fin qua 3
se vedi che tutto abbandonato magari non
c'è andare da sola però fa il cazzo che
vuole meno male che non ci sono
dentro ma che sta solo giocando sul
gioco che se non sarebbero cazzi cioè
proprio questa veramente la metà sale è
bellissimo sto gioco salvo residenti vol
ce l'ha fatta di giocare e basta
dove scolare io sto posto stufi del per
chi è stato chiesta chi è che mi ha
tirato una sprangata sulla testa sto
pezzente maledetto prime non mi sembra
proprio una praia tra essere in questa
prova un sacrosanto iddio mai sfogliato
pure su pervertito maledetto schifoso
laico che cazzo c'è un tubo lo sono nel
matrix a questi geni e censura
certamente del sindaco questa mezzi né
giampiero di censurare lavoro per
giampiero tutto a posto
jean ha cambiato molto la censura bravo
detto spa interessante studio attenzione
vini
ciao ciao bella lasciate pure i vestiti
un gentleman proprio mi sono svegliato
nella vasca da bagno con un tubo perché
ero connesso a un respiratore che
cacchio ne so però questo sempre il
soffione nella doccia però molto più
grosso secondo me non è basta filmati
fammi giocare che cacchio c'è un occhio
bendato non è normale ma non ho più
l'occhio
ad un occhio
kt no non è vero non tanto non lo so non
ho capito
berna
che schifo lo ha tolto un occhio ma sto
stronzo
la ragazza partito strana nostro gioco
porca vacca
e se ciò il salto vabbè non ho rimesso
la pelle genoma dai cioè che ha fatto
benissimo scusatemi ma è fatto veramente
bene
il diario di quelli a cui lei verges me
ne frega niente
cioè è partito malissimo nel senso va
tolto un occhio ma hanno denudata sti
stronzi dov'è che non trova la chiave
tra scusa a jean luc
ma tu puoi guardare in giro non
bellissimo ho trovato un orologio da
taschino va bene e qua c'è un lucchetto
ue bene avevi si può aprire al sole 12
35 però non so se 12 35 corretto
non lo so s purtroppo provo è proprio
lui come la gioca
va bene se la chiave qua no
che poi tra l'altro è fatto di legno
marcio sono aspetti che il potere
all'inter e cazzotti eccelleva prove
questo la uso per aprì la porta
ma perché mancava la maniglia mischia
fantastico devo aprire pure il kali
piaceva sto male mi sembra un po
eccessivo
poi le avere aperto a porta del resto
room madonna che brutto posto nove
ragazzi ma datemi prego datemi una
pistola qualcosa giorno buffon che c'è
se saleh un accendino interesse possa
accendere lo posso usare perché non vedo
una sega per cortesia
ok la lega bible c'è una sedia accesso
c'è una sedia accesso non vedo nessuna
criticità questo dove devo andare di qua
madonna che hanno rabbia ragazzi
pazzesco
ecco la camera girata madonna quanto
residenti volo io me ne andrei da
qualche altra parte non da sinistra
sicuramente vado adesso vado a destra oa
sinistra va bene che cosa sta succedendo
ma non lo so ma non hai un occhio quindi
non mi stupirei tantissimo nelle cose
dice andiamo avanti
domanda ma questo era un ospedale sul
serio il cast ci lavorava qua per
cortesia le mani che tengono le lanterne
ma tanto in tanto ci sono anche lei ci
sono anche le scritte sul muro non
correre prima cosa ma cosa che qua c'è
ma neanche è stata non si farebbe curare
il supporto ma cos'è è chiusa l'altra
parte sacrosanto gesù benedetto ti prego
datemi un crocifisso che è vietato
fumare da autisti pure non penso sia
quello il problema comunque c'è qualcuno
dietro
no no
non corre corro oddio forse era proprio
la porta brava la zia stanza raggi ics
era un tizio sulla serie l'hotel ma è un
robot
no la persona vero che profeta di piazza
mi scusi lei sa mica temi ha scavato un
occhio perché s'è visto che cosa
succedendo qua allora sicuramente non
sta giocando a forza 4 questo sicuro
sono liberate dalla national penso che
ci siamo conosciuti nella cappella solo
quale qualche paio di giorni fa si vede
che io sono la gemella e 2 incontrato la
mammella ai giovani membri un antico non
mi ricordo di te certamente non ricordo
il four un certo punto la trama io mi
hanno tolto un occhio permette alla mia
sorella fidati giocabili
avete visto mi sto sbagliando che più
confondo smesso
cosa succede padre dove sono tutti
qualcosa di malvagio sta succedendo sui
ma dai ma da cosa lo capisci con una
bibbia nella mia mano xmail dio mi
protegge ma io avrei tenuto anche che
cazzo e sta scritto su schema da mina
pistola santo ma cos'è ma con questa
pistola ad acqua cos'è sta roba hai un e
uno sparachiodi con aria compressa per
aumentarne la potenza cioè vale comunque
ragazzi e vado nella stanza del
generatore sembra un po eccessivo che li
porto io lo prenderei la cosa brutta è
che ho letto la luce o metto quello c'è
un posta in tutte e due
porca eva beh al piede di porco ma
attenzione attenzione proprio lui è
fatto benissimo saper bellissimo un
gioco della madonna scusa se quando
uscirà cupo ad uscirà perché questa è
una demo lo giocherò tantissimo è fatto
veramente bene ho trovato dei chiodi va
bene munizioni il problema quale è che
non vedo nulla non puoi tenere con una
mano questo e con l'altra mano l'altro
no hai una mano sola neanche tanto amato
la mappa cavato l'occhio è cene senza
portarle due mani
non è che devo andare anche i quali c'è
un'altra patata dalla porta è sbloccata
attenzione ma vaffan inaspettati
aspettate ci provo non ci credo
il buio il buio mi spaventa non devo
farmi prendere dalle ombre non posso
fare altro ma le aspetta che per quelli
sparo aspetta stufi che debutterà è
l'amore
e vabbè ma che cazzo sei ma scusa padre
è mailat un'arma di merda dammi qualcosa
da anni un fucile scusi morto non muore
stronzo di merda o per schivano
non lo so me non lo vedo e morto è morto
morto ma colpito è morto pezzo di merda
ma veramente c'è riuscito a farmi anche
colpire
sto bene però va bene l'ho ammazzato ho
sprecato 62 chiodi ma ne è valsa la pena
prendo il rum loro piace né le cose ha
girato avevano capito come oddio se pure
pagato
dovevo mettere 11 perché sta a fare
quando dalla botta va indietro tipo 1
kacar ma ce l'ho fatta
possono equipaggiare la pistola andare
in giro senza aver paura di cambiasso
almeno madonna che casino padre hai
visto
sono stato buon ciò anche una squadra
che secondo me la b la tua bibbia ha
aiutato meno fatto io e risk e brava ok
devo andare in libreria ragazzi che
andare al secondo piano e libri e
giornali brevi ha certo che in un posto
così l'unica può sud e vorrei arrivare
dall'interno popolari breve
mica voglio andarmene a gambe levate
come se non ci fosse un domani no
abbiamo libreria c'è mai un odore andare
in libreria
alla feltrinelli let's go il primo
episodio di charme angels domani farò il
secondo veramente un gioco figo vi
chiedo scusa se sono un po come
all'inizio l'ho già detto che sono un po
così ma poiché tacca di febbre quindi
sono un po stranito questi giorni ma
tutto tranquillo ci vediamo domani con
secondo episodio mini non mancate 900
ragazzi meno regione al momento il piace
anche ai sociali della giustizia e
fatemi sapere è pensata in gioco sono e
incredibile come siciliano hanno
perseguito dai ragazzi
[Musica]
no